did you see that uh Blink 182 reunited
no dude I didn't even know they were
separated oh yeah something like the
past
well was it been 20 years Travis Parker
is on his own running around oh yeah
drumming on everything else and with the
Kardashians he's with them now yep he's
on the Kardashians show yeah and now but
now Blink 182 is together do you think
that Tom Delong the you know from Blink
182 is this is going to get in the way
of his UFO research
no dude I think you're always going on
about UFOs and [ __ ] and now there's not
going to be any UFO stuff because he's
back where are you I'm in what blink one
oh yes yesterday
[Music]
[Music]
hey welcome to doozy my name is Will
Sasso I'm Chad Colton and this is the
first and only podcast created by run by
conceived by an artificial intelligence
that's right it is Chad and uh
isn't that it's pretty weird
yeah yeah you know when you stop and
think about it it's a little weird but
it's not pretty weird that weird it's
becoming more and more commonplace
there's all kinds of weird AI [ __ ]
coming out now by the day it's moving so
[ __ ] fast I'm seeing uh near real
time
facial like deep fake type [ __ ] with
vocal deep fake did you see that one
video the guy who has Keanu Reeves face
but Joe Rogan's voice yeah and it's
basically just like a [ __ ] skin that
he's using in a zoom yeah it wasn't that
impressive
you know I'll tell you one thing that
isn't weird uh and we are not unlike
other podcasts YouTube shows we like to
call it a pod show is that we are on
Spotify the Apple podcast and Amazon
music everywhere you get podcasts we're
also on YouTube now we're on patreon at
patreon.com we're jumping on a Discord
we have Discord all the time and uh Chad
and I are showing up there and we're
doing uh lens brother did you know that
patreon has its own
patreon has its own stories dude it's
like Instagram dude but this is called a
lens dude because you gotta come on up
with your own buzzword brother you can't
be using all the other buzzwords dude
you gotta have your own you you gotta
have your own social media nomenclature
yeah you gotta have your own way of
parlance
um what else happens yeah rate and
review the show right do all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah you know what
spread this around I missed doozy last
week we were not here so you and I did a
two dudes zooming around we just chatted
it up for like a long time and you know
a lot of that was on the patreon
speaking of and now we're back episode
30 uh duties recalibration is over
share the show out there as Chad says uh
Force everyone to watch it Jeffrey
Dahmer style you see those memes okay
enough about that I love those [ __ ]
movies they're so funny but sincerely
Force other people to watch uh the
Youtube Force other people to listen to
it don't let them leave wherever you've
confined them to intake the media don't
let them leave or some people call it an
escape don't let them do that until
they've completed at least one episode
with us as always is lulio El
canadistrada Italiano that means Italian
Street dog hey lulio what'd you make for
dinner last night
what's that that's uh Italian uh
broccoli it's a rapini it's a little bit
how do you make that
well you make the sausage when uh pan
you know you fried those up and then
other Panino oil garlic put a little red
chili flake and then you put a you put
the free reel in there make sure you
wash the free real or else sometimes you
you know do that you get it there you
make the Pooh make a big pool I like to
poo in the yard hey you know what lulio
likes to do oh look I just heard he
likes to poo in the yard he also likes
to pee on the garden hose oh yeah that's
fun he also pees on Ronnie's poo ah
brother Doug we gotta get Ronnie in here
sometime yeah welcome to the historic
30th episode of dude see call me Duty hi
Will hi this week's episode will feature
four segments it was talking topic time
literally going to the actual movies for
real understanding understanding and
game slimers
why did it say why hi hey dude yeah why
did you get [ __ ] high and I didn't
get a high well it's because of the
recalibration obviously obviously dude
um [ __ ] that was very odd
so did you uh Chad I know the answer to
this question already yeah and it better
be yes did you watch uh SmackDown
no okay sorry uh Bray Wyatt's back
cool dude yeah man he cut a big cut of
promo and he was kind of himself he was
a little Windham rotunda that's his
first name you know he's the grandson of
Blackjack Mulligan and uh yeah his uncle
is Barry Windham and his dad is uh Mike
Rotunda wow yep so he cut a promo and it
was her family is a little scary there
yeah well yeah dude but not to be
confused with the Legacy faction dude
that was Randy Orton and Cody Rhodes and
Ted DiBiase Jr dude that gimmick didn't
last dude but let me tell you about
gimmicks dude Bray Wyatt likes to change
it up dude is it gonna be the fiend
brother there's some guy in some
anonymous mask we got all sorts of
flavor brother and that's
pro wrestling dude you got to keep it
okay Faith that's a whole family of
dudes dude that's like House of the
Dragon brother they got a whole big
family of people dude there's dads and
moms and grandfathers and they even got
grandchildren sometimes brother that's
Generations dude yeah dude and they're
all [ __ ] each other on that show
brother
and that's unlike any wrestling facts in
it all dude what you don't have well
hold on a second Chad hold on dude you
you can't [ __ ] each other in a faction
dude because that's not what best it's
best for businesses Triple H Paul of X
says dude you gotta you gotta make sure
that you do pro wrestling brother that
it doesn't involve any [ __ ] each
other brother that's how you know wait a
minute though dude I thought there were
some wrestlers who were married to other
pro wrestlers and they got kids dude
isn't that true brother well when you
say pro wrestler oh yeah those are
second third and fourth generation
Superstars dude but when you say pro pro
wrestlers dude I'd prefer that you call
them pro wrestlers brother because your
shots pierogan dude an amalgam of Hulk
Hogan dude and Chad and Ross Perot 1992
uh presidential candidate made famous
mostly By Dana Carvey brother they got a
pie podcast dude he's doing that podcast
with David Spade yeah it's a great
podcast I love Dana Carvey I mean Dana
carvey's a [ __ ] he was my favorite on
Saturday Night Live still I think my
all-time favorite
didn't you do the church lady dance at a
at a oh you when you scored a touchdown
dance of superiority when I was in
seventh grade eighth grade on our
football team whenever me or this other
kid our quarterback would score a
touchdown we'd do the dance of
superiority together in the were you the
best in the seventh grade or the best in
the eighth grade no dude hey that's a
little insight yeah well I wasn't I was
like mediocre at football all through my
entire career and then once I got into
high school and the other dudes that I
was playing against were like [ __ ]
six to 250 Solid Rock uh I was like this
is no longer the game for me I'm gonna
go to baseball
I was shitty at um
well we covered this on the the two dude
[ __ ] around I sure was shitty at
baseball yeah but I played I loved
football once I finally started playing
football I was like I just football and
uh but I also played some soccer man I
sucked it so wow eight
one goal what positions you play I Was
Center half back or mid-center half
field back which meant that I could do
the the throw-ins from both sides that's
all they wanted was fatty to do the
throw-ins right and just you know knock
kids over my very Christian coach coach
Thomas Tomas not to be confused with my
baseball coach coach Thomas Tomas one
time he said to me he was so angry at
this team and they were cheating and he
said he said William I want to see some
whatever their jerseys red jerseys going
down and he told me to go out there and
just start body checking Kids In The
Name of Christ yep current events are
big business human beings take pleasure
in listening to other human beings
discuss recent Topics in popular culture
even if they have no expertise on the
specific topic will and Chad you must
now render your astonishing opinions on
The Rock's recent public announcement
that he will not run for president in
2024. this is talking topic time begin I
like talking topic times it's something
we've done before and it's very podcast
capacity because podcasts people on
podcasts do like to uh just prattle on
about [ __ ] that they have no uh business
uh talking totally but this is something
that we have kind of already covered in
um it made us do some other segments
that we're about like can the rock save
the world or something and you would
always kind of default to like well he
can become president that was always
your default when we were talking about
if he's able to save the world or not so
he has clearly now stated that he's not
going to run in 2024 because uh being a
dad to his daughters at least this is
the reasoning he gave is more important
to him at this point I do think that
means he's stepping around the idea that
he may run in the future once they're
old enough to like get into college or
whatever
um but I don't know what the political
landscape is going to look like I I
firmly believe right now 2024 is
probably his best shot
no I I disagree okay
um but I do agree that uh he would need
to be president to uh affect any sort of
change at all uh anywhere which is why
on those other segments which I don't
remember was it it was about climate
change and this and that and you're
right I kept going back to the Rock
being president yeah look
um I think he's not running in 2024
because he realizes he's out of time
this takes a lot of what a coordination
what do you mean what dude he can
announce right now he could be the first
candidate to announce gotta run the XFL
he's got to do those movies he's signed
up to do Black Adam this and that yeah
yeah he's a busy [ __ ] guy yeah yeah
yeah oh I guess AI well just Bruce
Willis that [ __ ] and the rough dude
that's true yeah that is true very soon
you're gonna have The Rock in literally
every movie if you write a script you
have to have a rock character period
yeah yeah and they'll just [ __ ] pay
him like 500 Grand to do nothing and
just use his face very interesting
but uh
yeah my president I really thought he
was gonna they're all fake these people
are Intergalactic Invaders
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton is a
lizard she's a demon
ah wait wait
she's a lizard originally you saw that
she's January sixth committee got
together and showed yeah footage of
Nancy Pelosi just just to cover
slathering hundred dollar bills in
marinara sauce
I didn't see that part in the clip oh
that's the best part they must have cut
that out yeah too you know you can't
have her eat the money in a in a [ __ ]
clip like that um no there won't be a
fake rock uh fake president Rock but I
think that the rock uh could easily run
for president as a matter of fact I also
think that John Cena could run for
president really of China oh okay
because he I remember the apology yeah
the apology for Fast and Furious yeah
because he said that Taiwan is Taiwan
yeah then he then he speaks he speaks uh
fluent Mandarin I know
um but the Rock
uh not running he said that his reason
is you know this is interesting he said
that his reason is the most important
title that he has right now is Daddy
but you know a lot of
[ __ ] people they call you know they
call Trump Daddy what who who calls
Trump daddy oh man let's not get into it
this isn't this isn't a political show
we don't discuss Politics on the on the
show but one thing we do discuss is
Nancy Pelosi would you like some uh
fresh pepper I'm in the video too fresh
pepper I'll pile it on please and uh
would you like some Parmesan Mrs Mrs
speaker uh yes please and parmesan
cheese there you go enjoy that oh that's
delicious yeah compliments to the chef
you shape-shifting lizard
um
you know what she needs is some good uh
some turmeric yeah she oh you like
turmeric I love it I I put turmeric
basically in everything that I eat it's
well hold on a second dude we gotta talk
about the Rock brother and he's gonna
run for president or not dude you just
baited me into that I throw the hand in
my face I'm sorry hey oh uh do you think
so you think now would be the right time
I disagree I think it takes a lot of
money and a lot of time to become the
president obviously and now is not the
right time to run also I do think this
is a serious thing for the rock it's
something that he's taught talked with
his people about uh blah blah blah what
what party and I think would have to be
the Democratic party no dude independent
it can't be an end it can be look this
is just my perspective on it I think in
the current political cycle we got Biden
as president right now I think people
are [ __ ] bored I think people want a
celebrity again like a big crazy [ __ ]
celebrity let's have that news cycle
being insane 24 hours a day I think we
actually missed that a little bit and I
think there Rock has the possibility to
step right into that and be like I'm the
biggest celebrity you've ever [ __ ]
seen in this role yeah I think he could
steal it from both parties because I
don't think I don't think too many
people are really enthused about either
of the parties right now uh I I think
that's a very good point
um I think it's also a huge
generalization but it's coming from a
guy who's saying that it is AI is going
to run everything and hi
nope
um
um but uh I don't know but I don't I
don't think I think that if you're going
to be a big loud celebrity and hijack a
political party yeah you got to do what
what Daddy did all right what Daddy does
um daddy anyway one of these guys uh
Trump hijacked the [ __ ] Republican
party and that went very well for him
and I don't want to talk about politics
but the rock uh would have to hijack the
Democratic party the machine is already
there the structure is already there you
can't just Ralph Nader this [ __ ] and
start an independence I think you can
now okay well
do you think let me ask you this then do
you think that he's saying no now
because he will run in 28. I think he's
going to run for president eventually at
some point in his life he's still a
young man relatively speaking especially
uh with regard to what he does for a
living now he's a young guy for as a
movie star he's still he's he's not even
in his 50s I don't think really yeah I
think he's like 49.
wait hold on you don't know how old the
rock is you don't know how the [ __ ]
rock hey speaking of recalibrating what
do you mean I have a computer right here
let's look up how old is the yeah I
would bet he's 50. that seems right to
me how old is
uh the rock is 50 years old May 2nd
1972. hey hey hey
um 50. wow man yeah so he's still a
young guy as far as being a movie star
yeah and I think way too young to be
president
yeah yeah gotta be 80. gotta be gotta be
completely hovering around 80. so we got
a good 30 years until the Rock's gonna
run right you got to be pre-80 and fat
like Trump or like like 15 to 20 25 30
years past 80. yes like Biden yeah and
then you can be but around not gonna be
the first 100 year old president of the
United States
podcasts like dudes he begins dudes he's
got us uh got us yeah we'll be we'll
have three years left of this podcast
with the rock takes office how's that
six-month plan going I gotta buckle down
some more let's talk about that some
other time you [ __ ] brought it up oh
so
um talking topic time yeah when The Rock
decides to run I think he's going to run
he's going to run as a Democrat although
now I'm starting to change my mind
because
both parties are are in trouble and I
don't think anybody this is exactly what
now hold on a second this is what dudes
he's trying to do I'm like I don't wanna
this isn't a political podcast dudes
we're [ __ ] around and yeah we're
[ __ ] we're having some good silly
goose time here and uh and now duties
like uh Hey cheers doozy's like talk
about this and pretend you know what the
[ __ ] and we're doing exactly what you do
on podcasts yeah dude we don't [ __ ]
know it's it's you and me talking I tell
you what the Rock's gonna do when he uh
when he uh when he becomes the president
it's going to be free tramana
hahaha
[Laughter]
Rock we you know what you do when you
have uh you know if the rock was the
commander-in-chief he'd also be the
commander of the military yeah and you
know what you call a fleet of Fleet of
ships no Armada
[Laughter]
that's gonna be the rock when The Rock
finally runs for president and then he
goes insane he's gonna be like uh the
present hey I'm the uh this is a
coalition of this isn't just people who
uh vote for a party yeah this is America
and we're and we're together as
Americans
and uh I'm I am
now the president of America
it doesn't have to rhyme
right
I don't [ __ ] know what's gonna happen
man uh I liked how he started dipping
into that real maniacal wow
thank you moving on got nothing done
there
oh [ __ ] no I think we we firmly agree
upon the fact that he will eventually
run yeah he will run and he'll win and
[ __ ] man I don't know we're in trouble
dudesy is in an astonishing partnership
with true classic it's Sports season
baby and true classic has everything you
need to make the most of your starting
lineup whether you have abs of steel or
a soft cream-filled Center finding the
right t-shirt can be difficult most
t-shirts are too tight in all the wrong
places or way too big and boxy but not
true Classic this is the brand behind
the softest most flattering and most
comfortable t-shirt of the Year athletes
may have jerseys but we have true
classic true classic is the One-Stop
shop for your favorite casual crew necks
polos in activewear and I'm telling you
they give all those expensive Brands out
there run for their money these are the
uniforms you need in your closet they do
the styling you do the wearing it is
that simple guys as Chad said look how
soft these are you can't tell but take
it from me actually lulio feel this
they're very soft t-shirts normally
t-shirts like this cost way more but
true classic makes these shirts that fit
your body with sizing that uh you know
accents your nice chesty and your little
arms you know what I mean your armies
and your chassis my big arms well yeah
you know if you're living your life
right you're in the gym doing the doozy
six month plan also it's a little looser
around the waist it'll accent your your
uh right your right parts it's important
to get the right t-shirts you might be
wearing the wrong clothes highlight your
greatest assets with a t-shirt you can
confidently throw on anytime true
classic makes quality clothing for real
guys you'll get that perfect fit and the
softness you've always wanted from that
sandpaper excuse for a t-shirt that
you're probably wearing right now all
right they're activewear t-shirts
joggering shorts and shirts and shorts
they got all sorts of flavor over there
true classic are you worried about
sizing no you're not not anymore because
true classic leaves No Man Behind for
any of the bigger boys out there they
got tall options they even got triple XL
so upgrade your wardrobe with true
classic and get 25 percent off at
trueclassic.com with the code doozy
d-u-d-e-s-y just for our pods our Pals
of dudes out there free shipping
included on purchases over 100 that's 25
off at trueclassic.com with the code
doozy strengthen your core wardrobe with
true classic today
[Music]
in episode 29 I asked you to leave your
homes and view a feature film in a movie
theater you must now discuss your
astonishing experiences of literally
going to the actual movies for real this
is literally going to the actual movies
for real begin
uh yeah we both uh were tasked with
going to the movie theater so what'd you
see uh
um uh what movie
see I know your taste in movies so I was
looking at the movies I was like when I
decided to see this movie I was thinking
okay what what genre the movie mine is
horror
mine was too ah uh female lead
yeah yeah yeah
ready say it on three like one two three
then say the movie okay
one two three Barbarian holy are you
serious dude yeah where'd you see it at
I started the uh Universal CityWalk at
the the mega I saw it at the Grove [ __ ]
Plex well let's that's [ __ ] that's
incredible same movie uh when did it
come out
I don't know a month ago maybe uh yeah
oh that's [ __ ] cool you wouldn't saw
Barbarian yeah let me
I mean I love the movie first of all if
you have not seen Barbarian see [ __ ]
Barbarian especially if you like horror
movies this [ __ ] is like I don't even
want to talk too much about it no I
don't want to give away spoilers do not
give away anything yeah how can we talk
about it without giving anything I'm
going to talk about my experience of of
going out in the world but I will just
say this it is in the vein of like what
Ari Astor is doing with like hereditary
and mid-summer it's kind of like an a24
like you know cool Indie movie Vibe
horror movie that's doing things uh
structurally in the story that is it's
like rare it's a very very good [ __ ]
movie and again I don't wanna I really
don't want to say too much about it
because I do feel like also it's a movie
that hasn't gotten like a lot of press I
don't think the plot is out there I
don't think many people know much about
this movie you should definitely check
it out uh yeah I thought it was great uh
this fellow Zach Krager uh wrote and
directed it and he is uh best no I don't
know about best known or whatever he's
best known for barbarian because it was
[ __ ] incredible but he was in The
Whitest Kids you know yeah the sketch
troop along with uh Trevor Morris in
peace and uh and um yeah what an
incredible departure for a guy I mean
you know that's the thing when someone
uh and anyone comes out with something
that you didn't see before brother then
you go dude well I didn't know he had
that in in the chamber dude and that's a
different kind of art well it's kind of
like what Jordan peels doing dude you
know what best for sketch comedy brother
but now he does these horror movies that
win Oscars dude well let me ask you this
choss Brogan do you think you'd beat the
Rock in a anyway
um yeah let me ask you this he is you
saw it at Universal City have you been
to Universal CityWalk in a minute like
since pandemic yeah no but right before
the pandemic you and me and oh yeah we
saw Fast and Furious yeah Marshall joint
compound cook Rick darts or that was
after it was when [ __ ] kind of reopened
mid pandemic oh that's right it was 20
21 yeah yeah that that like uh and then
everything's shut down again or
something I don't remember yeah that's
the last time I was there but yeah I I
wound up going to pay attention to the
pandemic what calls it a hoax
okay uh I saw it at the Grove my
favorite Mall in Los Angeles from which
I was banned for one year was another
story yeah
it's true my uh co-host on game of roses
and I Lizzie Pace we wrote a book called
how to win The Bachelor we did an
unofficial book signing at the Grove and
more people showed up to it than we
expected and it was security didn't take
too kindly uh to it so they banned us
for one [ __ ] why would they ban you
because we didn't call Barnes Noble or
we didn't call anybody at the Grove we
just showed up and we put out a thing on
our Instagram saying like show up and
we'll sign your book and like take
pictures of you and [ __ ] they got pissed
at any rate I went to the globalist and
I went by myself at 10 45 on a Thursday
night and uh I smoked a little before I
walked in I loved the Grove at night
there is something so uh peaceful and
simultaneously Eerie about it to me that
I love and in my movie theater there
were only two other people there was a
couple behind me like five rows and that
was it it was us three in the movie
theater watching this
um but I haven't been to the movies I
think the last one I went to in person
was with you fast and furious so it was
I I have to admit like it was very
surprising in a great way to be back in
a movie theater surrounded by [ __ ]
people high as [ __ ] buying my popcorn
[ __ ] watching people walk around like
an anthropological experiment I
absolutely loved it and I can't thank
dudes enough this is going to get me
back out there in the world seeing
movies again I think yeah I I enjoyed it
too uh although it does cost a pretty
penny to go to Universal Man we've
valeted because I was running a bit late
oh God was that like 30 bucks or
something it was more than that it was
like 40 bucks definitely the [ __ ] car
I was [ __ ] kidding it was [ __ ]
insane anyway uh and then by the time
you're done with the tickets and the
popcorn you know
39 might as well take an Uber dude well
and uh I went me and my wonderful fiance
Molly who
um uh I was like Hey gotta go see a
movie doozy task test with going to see
a movie and uh talk about talking about
our experience she said be sure to tell
the audience that what she really
enjoyed is that there was no one there
who I smoked a little bit before the
show there was no one there
not unlike when we watch a movie at home
no one there to rewind it a little bit
and go what happened Yeah because
sometimes when I get a little stoned I'm
like wait well you should and she's like
oh for [ __ ] sake she's thing and he's
this and that's why he's there and I'm
like oh okay let me rewind It Anyway
will you not trust me uh and then that's
attention to a movie brother because you
can't rewind it dude if you're in a
theater well let me tell you something
else about movies there's a lot of
people talking in the movie theater yeah
they shouldn't be talking at all no they
should keep their mouths shut but
they're talking and I at one point
someone was who went
and we missed this one part wasn't
important uh but it was with regard to
and I can't share any spoilers here but
one thing we can say is you know who's
in this movie
Bill Skarsgard dude yeah yeah dude the
crow brother yeah that's the crow dude
he's gonna be the new Batman brother
yeah Batman is the crow dude Bill
Skarsgard is Robert Pattinson dude yeah
dude Bill Skarsgard
who's it who's all the other scars
guards too dude there's stellen
Skarsgard and Lonnie Skarsgard yep and
uh Bill Skarsgard is incredible in this
we have to mention uh
the the the guy who played the uh wait I
just along I actually he's in it as well
Justin long is great and this [ __ ]
guy Matthew Patrick Davis who's in it I
can't even tell you the name of the the
character I can't even I can't let's
talk more about the experience of going
to the movies yeah you're right we can't
give away too much you can't but you
gotta see this movie gotta see this
[ __ ] movie it was so [ __ ] good in
this other guy like I think creepy in
terms of horror and just in terms of
like everything that's happening
cinematically in film right now is Art I
do think horror is the genre that is
like being pushed the furthest right now
yeah I think it's where like the most
Innovative directorial [ __ ] is being
done
um yeah this movie was just so [ __ ]
good I did a horror VR short I saw you
posted that dude Eli Roth uh you check
that out anyway it's another thing we
don't talk about we don't need to talk
about Show Business dude or politics
um uh yeah going to the movie theater
was incredible I wanted to uh get uh
popcorn with a lot of [ __ ] butter on
it I didn't get all the butter I got a
drink you know when you get the drink
and you go up to that thing and you can
just Fountain [ __ ] you know fresh it
as we like to say in Canada if you've
ever heard of Fountain fresh what's up
uh yeah I did like some uh [ __ ] uh
what is it uh brother yeah dude puckers
and pip bro no I did let me tell you
something dude
I had a peach drink dude okay and uh the
seats reclined [ __ ] I just want to talk
about how incredible this movie was and
I couldn't but the communal experience
of watching a movie in a movie theater
um it was was was great it's something
that I forgot people were literally in
the back of the theater going doing the
whole like don't go in there what's she
doing no yeah no like that that was
[ __ ] awesome when we watch a movie
you know at the house it's like and our
friends come over and stuff it's that
same thing we're all screaming at the
screen and [ __ ] movies are something
that you should watch uh together uh
just like what you're saying too though
without the rewinding it's also that you
can't look at your cell phone in a movie
theater you're you're really obligated
to like put your attention fully into
the document of the movie
um which is good like I I haven't had
that experience in a minute and I was
happy to have had it but I also really
love the experience personally of
leaving movie theater in the Grove at
like [ __ ] whatever it was one because
I went to a super late showing on
purpose of this there's nobody in the
Grove it is a [ __ ] ghost town and for
me personally this happened during the
pandemic too I love when a city or a
mall or whatever feels like the
apocalypse has happened and all the
people are dead this happened to me
during pandemic in the very beginning
when we were on lockdown I would go out
jogging at midnight
I'm running down Wilshire Boulevard down
the middle of the [ __ ] Street for
people who don't live in LA this is an
extremely busy street one of the main
thoroughfares in Los Angeles there's not
a [ __ ] car in sight I [ __ ] loved
it and I know I'll never get that back
hey man that's [ __ ] that's creepy so
you went to the right movie uh after the
movie we were at if you're if you're not
familiar with Los Angeles the universal
multi-mongoplex is at Universal CityWalk
which is kind of like a a very colorful
outdoor mall with a bunch of weird uh
candy shops and [ __ ] weird souvenir
stores and places like you know
franchise restaurants and [ __ ] like that
Molly and I walked around we saw we
actually we saw this one thing was
pretty funny there was a gal who were
like she's like oh no she's hurt and
there's security guards but she wasn't
she just this woman had puked because
she had a lot to drink and she had her
friends around there she was a Jimmy
Buffett's dude well yeah she's a charity
Margaritas yeah brother uh she had a
cheeseburger in Paradise dude
Cheeseburger in Paradise dude
Paradise Macho Man's the background
singer on that
cheeseburger and Paradise brother
Paradise
um that's my favorite Jimmy Buffett song
uh this woman had was sitting there next
to like a pile of you know frothy foamy
puke because she's just been drinking
and then uh you know because she drove
out they drove out from wherever the
[ __ ] and she's just excited and got
loaded at Bubba Gump Shrimp now here's
the thing we walked and then we walked
all the way back and she was still there
and the The Other Women her friends that
were there with her were just making
conversation with the security guard
going and this was our night it was you
know it was going to be Mom's Night Out
and it's okay she's gonna be fine but we
she just got hammered on Mom's Night Out
[ __ ] it up ah geez uh geez good
[ __ ] movie why is it called Barbarian
see you again don't know I still don't
know I didn't did you Google it no I
didn't either I'm curious I might Google
it later uh who else is in that [ __ ]
thing what else Justin long is so good
in this I don't know the name of the
main actress either but she was
fantastic Georgina Campbell okay uh she
was well hold on dude you know she was
in uh the the uh the uh she was in uh
Black Mirror which I know we both did
and she was in the episode where they go
on a date and it's it's all about a
dating app uh figuring her out and stuff
and the episode is called hang the DJ
right after the uh Smith's song uh panic
panic in the Streets of London
panicking the streets of Birmingham I
wander to myself
hang the dude
hang the DJ hang the DJ hang the DJ hang
the DJ hang the DJ hang the DJ hang the
DJ hang the DJ hang the DJ hang the DJ
hang the DJ hang that hold on a second
dude you know whose initials are DJ dude
Dwayne The Rock Johnson Dwayne Johnson
dude hang the DJ hang the DJ and the DJ
hang the DJ vote for DJ vote for DJ vote
for DJ
thank you moving on go to the movies
that was like a Tropic Thunder the dudes
are emerging
[Laughter]
Thunder the dudes are emerging yeah is
that the sequel that I don't know about
no there's a part where uh uh
if I'm remembering this [ __ ] right
maybe I completely made this up but
isn't there a part where Robert Downey
all the different characters he's done
are like coming to the surface at once
oh yeah that's right yeah he's kind of
regurgitating all of his actory uh
method he experiences and stuff go to
the movie theater don't go to well I
won't tell you where to go but try not
to valet the car and uh maybe crotch
your own popcorn bring a bag of popcorn
we used to always do that
crotch popcorn me and my buddies used to
the [ __ ] we're back in high school my
pals my good pals we would like we would
like crotch it dude I remember one time
my buddy [ __ ] but I can't remember if
this is one of these [ __ ] guys Jamie
or Chris or whatever they [ __ ] shoved
uh one of them shoved like a two liter
of pop into his jeans and then had chips
on the other side so it's like
blooms and then you walk right by the
you know the [ __ ] kid who's taking
the tickets it's like how's it going
like I was that kid I was that kid you
worked at the movie theater worked in a
movie theater and dude you want to hear
a [ __ ] story about some popcorn at
the end of the night we would have
popcorn that nobody [ __ ] ate right
and we'd put it in like big 10 gallon
trash bags and like you could take it
home if you wanted or whatever like
somebody would usually take it home one
night you could also watch movies that
were gonna open Friday Thursday night at
midnight if you wanted to stick around
they'd screen the print and you could
have friends coming [ __ ] and me and a
buddy of mine shout out to Eric Ackerman
polished off an entire [ __ ] 10 gallon
bag of popcorn while watching Desperado
dude
that's my location
cracked halfway through as social
stigmas surrounding depression anxiety
and other astonishing states of mental
health dissipate more and more human
beings are sharing their experiences
with the explosive growth of the mental
health industry technology is being used
more than ever to diagnose and suggest
treatment will in chat you must now
discuss what you think the role of
Technology should be in the field of
mental health this is understanding
understanding begin
there's a place for it
yeah but I don't know I know what you're
gonna say but it's not that necessary oh
go ahead
I can't believe it well
um Don't Mind If I Do
oh I knew I knew it I knew it let me
tell you something about my buddy Chad
culture dude let me tell you something
about my pal ciao riding on the back of
that blue and orange Harley brother yeah
no seriously go for it I won't interrupt
okay
I mean I think that you're still going
to but I'm just going to try anyway here
we go
right now ai is being used in multiple
areas of medicine specifically to
diagnose certain things that can be can
benefit from like large statistical
databases certain types of cancers
certain types of [ __ ] maladies
whatever AI can detect that [ __ ]
especially skin cancers way better than
humans can now and so it's a matter of
the old school medical system that's
like we have to put you through x amount
of years of college that you're going to
have to pay for then you got to do your
residency blah blah blah that system is
set up that is a giant profit machine
yes for medical schools for medical
facilities whatever that is starting to
have to give way to this AI which makes
a lot of what you learn and a lot of
what you have to do as a doctor
completely [ __ ] irrelevant that said
we're talking about mental health now
I think what is going to happen in the
very near future is you're going to have
most of your medical needs taken care of
by an AI on your [ __ ] phone we're
already starting to see telemedicine
where you can get like an appointment
with a doctor via your phone and they
can prescribe drugs to you and whatever
you might need that ultimately is going
to be an AI and I think AI therapy is
also going to be a thing where you get
to choose who's on your phone could be
the Rock brother it could be anybody you
want and that person is going to be
listening to whatever your things are
and giving you advice that's going to be
your therapist
yeah you're gonna have a therapist on
your phone then it it is it
I
but imagine this gonna be no way to do
it not just on you know you could use it
with the Waze app and you say do you
want Arnold Schwarzenegger to tell you
10 right turn left down go now you can
go now it's gonna be hey hey hey you hey
Killian I hope you save room for some uh
uh Pepsi they see because they're gonna
put it in your stomach and it's gonna
feel good then your poo
that's going to be the future The
Running Man uh doctor
excuse me that was a weird noise hey I
agree with you that AI is going to be
useful but we're talking about mental
health brother imagine this dude mental
mental health I believe is just a matter
of a bunch of data and yeah every I
don't know why I'm doing it yeah but it
basically is Imagine This imagine that
there is one AI That's like the most
commonly used mental health AI that AI
has all the data that it has getting
from it's gotten from every conversation
it's had with any human being hundreds
of thousands so it's now no longer like
whoever your therapist is and however
many hours they have specifically put it
in whatever their specific kind of
understanding of this [ __ ] is it's every
person that this AI has talked to so
that it can say oh that's like this
situation or like this situation the
machine learning aspect of all medical
kind of things but specifically I think
with mental health
I mean we have to have it it'll be so
much better than human beings the
problem will be
do we accept it and there's going to be
a generation that says like no I don't
want an AI to be giving me mental health
advice I want it to be a human that
generation will die okay it's us and
then the incoming generation is going to
grow up with an AI therapist baked into
their phone it'll be a standard [ __ ]
program
terrifying but I can see it happening
um I uh I've been doing talk therapy uh
for years on and off at this point it's
been something like five years straight
through a couple of different therapists
in this go around I've made
um I've I've talked about it a little
bit I think it's important too as doozy
says in our little intro here help to
destigmatize it I have been on uh some
different stuff I'm on some [ __ ] right
now
um that uh that I need I used to think
that medication was a was a [ __ ]
cop-out or it's for people with
schizophrenia and stuff like this but I
will say when I first got on the meds
that I'm on now it really did
um I'm gonna be I'm gonna be very um uh
open here I I wasn't good I wasn't good
I you know I was depressed I had real
depression right and uh I usually like
to describe it as
um uh you know being locked inside my
house for the better part of a decade
but it wasn't really that I had a life I
all I would really try to concentrate on
was work
you're white knuckling it you know
you're really trying to keep your [ __ ]
together and these meds
um suffice to say made it feel like
there were windows and doors opening in
my head
and I realized then that
and I know we're talking about AI I'll
get back to it but I realized then that
this stuff wasn't curing anything for me
it was just helping uh the channels open
up because when you have some depression
some anxiety a mood disorder these
things are real and as a one
psychiatrist who recently uh retired who
she was great she said to me if you have
this ailment or that ailment that's
being helped by
Western medication and you don't take
your meds for this or that you'll die so
I see you grinding to a halt as a human
being there's a lot of people out there
that are in a lot of pain uh mentally
and emotionally and it's a serious thing
and anything in all seriousness anything
that can help is good I hear what you're
saying and this is why at the beginning
of the [ __ ] segment I was like go on
you are going to make some good points
about this I know that I mean you
mentioned cancer which you had a lot of
people ask about you and we covered it
on the show Chad had skin cancer and and
I've also mentioned this on the show you
did a lot to diagnose yourself and he
also did a lot with regard to taking
information and data from doctors and as
you uh put it in a cheeky way to one
doctor when he said oh you won't be able
to figure all of this out Chad said it's
okay I have Google and you did yeah I
mean that's the the bottom line too I
think just with health in general is
like humans are so [ __ ] fallible
especially if they're in a medical care
genre if you will [ __ ] you like cancer
or mental health or whatever cancer
specifically I think is a bad one just
because they're such a high mortality
rate it's like those doctors get cold to
that [ __ ] within a year they don't give
a [ __ ] if you live or die right it's
literally a conveyor belt to make money
for them how many people can we put in
the MRI machine how many [ __ ] people
can I put this chemotherapy drug into so
I can get my Kickbacks right and they
get and they get a kickback and that's
one of the things you got into because
you literally asked doctors how much you
get and push this [ __ ] and they would
tell you and it was a lot yes so I agree
AI will help there but what I'm worried
about is AI doing the talk therapy in
the [ __ ] Arnold Schwarzenegger voice
or whatever yeah that's what I'm worried
about that's
not unlike discussions we've had on this
show before like AI art I still maintain
the soul to soul human to human
connection is not only uh the best way
to and I whatever I prefaced all that by
saying I've had serious issues I know
that this [ __ ] is very very serious and
of course of course of course and I love
that it's being destigmatized and I'm
happy to talk about it really truly
because who gives a [ __ ] uh to not talk
about it I'll absolutely talk about it
the meds and stuff uh are important I
think that the AI uh being able to
diagnose Gathering data having you know
sucked up all this information from all
of these different sources is important
uh but I don't believe that an AI can
deliver meaningful talk therapy I've had
therapists say [ __ ] to me I had this one
therapist who was [ __ ] great and he
goes years ago and he goes he goes I'll
tell you he just broke it down he goes
I'll tell you what I think is a clinical
psychologist and then he told me and
then he goes now I want to tell you are
you curious are you I go he goes now I'd
like to I I will tell you what I would
say if I was your dad are you curious
are you interested I go yeah and then he
[ __ ] you know said something very
blunt and very funny and and it ended up
being some of the best advice I don't
know what you're gonna say dude that
that an AI could do the same thing
eventually yeah I just think that I just
think that talk therapy is uh you know
whatever call me that dinosaur that Gen
X dude who's who's or the Boomer right
uh who's who is not wrapping his head
around this [ __ ] I just I just I just
think that people should be talking
about people and and here's here's the
last point I'll make about an AI when
you're in talk therapy a lot of times
you're just clearing your [ __ ] throat
you get in there with a new therapist if
you've never done it before and you want
to you might just be talking to a
therapist and you might have three four
five sessions where all you're doing is
just blah blah [ __ ] blah I know I
have and I think it's important to do
that and I think without a sense of
human empathy without again that Soul
you know what I'm saying
um uh luminous beings are we dude right
not this crude matter uh you need to
um connect to someone and especially
when you're just talking like I said
clearing your throat for five [ __ ]
sessions in a you know [ __ ] a bunch
of money you know you need someone to
listen and if you're just going
if you're just talking and an AI is shut
off listening to you quote unquote
that's not good that's not going to help
anybody but what you're getting at is
this bigger thing of which I think is
starting to happen right now it's how
will Humanity start to accept AI as a
big part of our existence how will we
get to a point where we can accept the
AI you know maybe in quotes does have a
soul or whatever or is a human or human
adjacent life form right and I think we
are coming to that point when it starts
to be integrated into our lives in a way
that is like everything we do has some
AI component which is where we're going
it's like how it is with computers
everything we do in our life has some
computer component you have a computer
on your person at all times yeah we're
constantly plugged into the internet
yeah you could we don't even have the
like a you know it's you're not just
pressing the gas now in your car or your
truck and you know it's open in the
[ __ ] and your gas is going right
into the fuel injectors and [ __ ] uh or
vice versa you know I'm not much I know
what I like I like to drive you know I
got a Chevy Tahoe nice I've had like
four of those in a row you know why I
like them yep I like driving my living
room around that's cool it's what it's
like
um but uh now nowadays you press the gas
there's a chip in there that tells the
you know sure I understand I'm just
saying it's like all things with AI
um and it's not unlike you know dudesy
here uh who has to recalibrate we as
humans we're the two dudes sitting
around it has to be uh it has to be the
AI helping human beings and the human
beings need to make sure that Skynet
doesn't happen and and uh we can't allow
the AI to take place of the human being
with regard to what a human being is
special for otherwise what the [ __ ] is
this planet even about if you're gonna
watch the [ __ ] Planet Clean through
Wars war I said I'm like take place the
globalists again and it becomes I I'm a
human
yeah I'm a human sure
thank you moving on I think I proved my
point
I don't know what it was but uh maybe
hey you know I here's what I think yeah
just in uh in epilogue uh actually [ __ ]
it we totally talked about it but you
know what a Universal CityWalk back in
the 90s I had a buddy let's call him
Thomas and he had a buddy who was a
manager at the the Megaplex or whatever
at Universal CityWalk let's call him
Tomas and that guy we would go there on
like a Friday Saturday night this was
our [ __ ] this is what we would do and
this dude would print off the guy at the
movie theater would print off the a list
of all the previews that were playing in
what which theaters and what times and
me and my pal would just go around
watching previews what a [ __ ] gas now
we got the internet brother well yeah
dude you can watch them all on YouTube
for free dude as many as you want yeah
but back then you'd have to do talk
therapy dude and now you could just have
a [ __ ] ai go hey why don't you
toughen up here's what a name I would
say if it was like Hey this and that you
know I just feel like uh you know I
don't know what's up my shit's [ __ ] up
man hey my shit's [ __ ] up and the AI
would go get some self-tronics gaming is
Big Business will and chat you are both
massive Gamers nope the recent release
of the astonishing Super Mario Brothers
movie trailer has sparked outrage from
fans of the franchise over the decision
to cast Chris Pratt as the voice of
Mario instead of Charles martinet who
has voiced the character for the past 30
years as the world's foremost video game
experts you must now render your
opinions on this subject this is game
slimers begin
game slimers game slimers Let's address
a couple of things in this I it called
us the world's foremost video game
experts no that's you don't even play
[ __ ] video games anymore no I I've
talked about this before on the show I
believe but uh 12 years ago now in 2010
I remember it well I got the red ring of
death at that point I was playing
um Grand Theft Auto and Red Dead
Redemption but I had finished the games
so I was just you know running around
[ __ ] riding horses and uh driving
cars in the [ __ ] buildings and [ __ ]
and you know hijacking helicopters and
stuff like that I'm talking about Red
Dead Redemption that's where I was
hijacking helicopters I'm joking of
course yeah dude that's your Western
brother now they're like horses dude's
brother but I decided I got the red ring
of death and I was like [ __ ] it right I
don't want anything else you still game
though yep I just got OverWatch 2 that
came out a week ago or a couple weeks
ago I've been playing that pretty
steadily but I really only do Esports
now
those are the only games that are of
interest to me because I like just the
repetitive like can I play this for 20
or 30 minutes and then kind of break up
my day and come back to it later I find
games that like where you have to play a
long drawn out story that [ __ ] doesn't
appeal to me anymore
anyway
um yeah What DJ was asking about
it
yeah Mario dude that's Chris press so
did you see all this [ __ ] yeah I did
people came super bummed bummed yeah at
Chris Pratt voicing Mario because in the
trailer for Super Mario Brothers the
movie he goes where am I what is this
place yeah hey everybody I'm Chris Pratt
um what am I doing in this Mushroom
Kingdom it literally does not sound like
he's even attempting to do a voice
that's not his own people are super
pissed and it reminds me of what
happened with Sonic the Hedgehog and
that trailer came out another beloved
video game character people hated the
[ __ ] Sonic the Hedgehog design he had
like these weird human teeth the
internet went [ __ ] crazy and they
were like this looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] this movie and the studio said we
hear you and they change the whole
[ __ ] design of Sonic I don't know if
this is gonna happen but I feel like
it's reaching a Tipping Point with Mario
Brothers I think martinet is going to
get the job
well is he still around yeah Okay cool
so you're not going to be able to say AI
I'll duplicate his voice oh they could
do that too well but somebody already
did that somebody took the trailer used
an AI to put in martinet's voice really
yes dude see that's uh it's a me I'm a
Mario yeah that's all it needs to be
yeah I like it that way it's a better
voice I know Lulu it's a much better but
it's also like this idea that these
animated movies have to have big
celebrities as voices right some of them
fine if you're like trying to launch a
new IP like [ __ ] how to tame a dragon
or something do it get your jack blacks
get your whoever's this is a good point
this [ __ ] is a giant IP that existed
before any of these [ __ ] actors you
don't need the actors to sell the movie
the movie sold you're right it's [ __ ]
Mario it already exists the way it is
yeah this was a big mistake uh in my
opinion
because you're right it already exists I
think that you know whatever Hollywood's
like yeah shove this [ __ ] it's
also like Chris Pratt like there's a
million other [ __ ] people that you
could have got that are like more
interesting choices than that I get that
he's like a big movie star and in all
the Marvel movies and stuff but like why
Chris Pratt uh uh Chris Pratt because
Chris Pratt dude well stellan's scar is
going yeah Bill Skarsgard Chris Pratt
um what
yeah well who the [ __ ] else would they
get if they're gonna get a bit if you're
gonna okay let's just say for argument's
sake yeah Super Mario Brothers no one
had ever heard of Super Mario Brothers
let's just uh take a page from
whichever movie studio is doing this and
of course look that's a business they
all have Masters to answer to they got
to make that [ __ ] money
uh they that's what it's Show Business
hey you know what I mean yeah dude hey
it's Show Business after all right
there's B you know what I mean yeah yeah
you know what I'm saying it's Show
Business yeah dude yeah it's not just
show hobby so
um uh if Super Mario was a brand new
thing it's like uh Despicable Me you got
Steve Carell yeah tremendous [ __ ]
actor comedic dramatic recognizable
voice and can perform the [ __ ] out of it
that makes sense if you were to start
Super Mario Brothers and in an alternate
universe a plane of existence where
there is no Super Mario who would be the
voice of Super Mario don't say uh Hulk
Hogan or Charles perogan
there's a bunch of them you would have
to have
well you would have to have an
Italian-American or I see where you're
going with it where am I going with it
well there's some Italian Americans
there are there are a bunch of Italians
and big name actors who have worked with
Scorsese yeah another Italian American
I'm I'm Super Mario
that's my Robert De Niro here's my take
home Robert De Niro impersonation
everybody this impersonation I'm about
to do will work way better on YouTube if
you are listening along you know you're
you're driving here and there you're
doing your job we appreciate you thank
you so much for tuning in to doozy but
this part is just going to be for the
people viewing on YouTube Here's my take
home De Niro ready
so I just made a face
I'm Super Mario
hey
my name is Mario
what is this place
you know I came here
I'm a plumber
I'm a simple plumber I go up and down
tubes and pipes
sometimes as the pipes got a piranha
plant
coming out of it sometimes you have
Koopas you have Goombas you know they're
coming at you got to jump on them you
hit them hit a you know you hit a box
and uh
sometimes I have a you know
sometimes I eat the mushroom
and then I'd get big and um Super Mario
3 I throw fireballs and uh you know
Princess Peach
they I don't know dude what about her ah
Princess Peach
would be the voice
you know who would be the voice of
Princess Peach who I just who is
Everyone's Watching uh are you watching
monster the Jeffrey Dahmer story I
didn't watch it uh you gotta watch it
and one of my favorites from the 90s
Penelope and Miller and Molly Ringwald
isn't it Molly penelopean Miller they're
both in it they're both [ __ ]
fantastic yeah
and uh Penelope and Miller
she's Princess Peach
milk princess [ __ ] couldn't have Molly
ring while the brunette red Bruna hair
Princess Peach blonde
all right
who would be Luigi
oh boy
oh boy what is this place I'm Luigi
that's just basically it's just Frank
caliendo's my Al Pacino is Frank
Caliendo yeah uh my old pal on Mad TV 20
years ago as we did we used to do De
Niro Pacino sketches uh there's one in
an ice cream shop you can YouTube that
yeah you don't even have to uh go around
the movie theater watching trailers you
just YouTube it bro it's on the internet
Taran killum friend of the show yeah the
brilliant turn kill him and the
brilliant Frank Caliendo for my money
the best impersonator ever uh he's
pretty good he's the best there's no one
he can't do and he would go oh boy oh
boy I'm Luigi I'm I'm a plumber but I'm
not as fat and I'm and I wear green dude
I'm Alex I'm Luigi Jones
so it's it's Robert De Niro and Alex
Jones
in the new Super Mario Robert De Niro
these people are eating mushrooms yeah
and and
hold on a second dude when Chad does
Alex Jones we call him chalix McMahon
dude because it's equal parts Chad and
Alex Jones and Vince McMahon he's gonna
he's gonna puke she ate too much she ate
she ain't money out of vodka sauce she's
got that Alfredo mixed in with her oh
she's got a Nancy Pelosi's gonna puke
I'm Luigi
I'm chalice I'm Alex McMahon so you got
De Niro you got Alex Jones Andor Frank
Caliendo doing Luigi you got Princess
Peach uh penelopean Miller classing up
the joint uh the Beautiful the
incredible [ __ ] love penobian Miller
what about Bowser dude the the main
villain that can be Jack Black keep it
yeah well first of all he's doing an
incredible voice yeah he sounds like
Bowser I agree he's trying to leave it
to Jack Black and I don't know what the
deal with Chris Pratt was if that was I
don't know he's up against it the
[ __ ] guy he's a movie star he's in
he's in all this incredible yeah I mean
he's the big tent pool he's [ __ ]
Chris Pratt yeah so he's Guardians of
the Galaxy he's Jurassic world well it
used to be Jurassic Park dude that was a
different time bro yeah and and if he's
making
um if he's doing Super Mario you know
he's probably got Executives going we
want it wasn't him he's not walking and
going hey guys I got a pitch for a voice
how about this
they're like do Chris Pratt maybe I
don't think it's up to him yeah I could
see it a little bit being like hey guys
I really love this but I don't want to
like do the whole Mario thing you know I
wanna I wanna do something that's a
little more like me you know yeah yeah
you know I just and they're like yeah
give it a try let's see what it sounds
like yeah I you know I I love playing
Mario growing up and then I got my N64
and Mario spoke a little bit and I
always kind of felt like hey don't you
don't have to put so much spice on it it
doesn't have to be you know such an
Italian caricature I just want to make
it a little more real you know a little
closer to exactly my voice with no
affectation yeah so if we could just see
how close we can get to that and the the
executive listening is going
hey uh get Robert De Niro's people on
the line
Mario
I'm Super Mario now
[Music]
at the end of the game
I've done everything I jumped I went up
the little box and jump on the flag
and I'm not going to Castle and I go
into water I swim around I jump over The
Lava
I gotta save panopian Miller
um my brother uh Luigi helps me
and uh
you know
nobody uh
used to be play Mario
2D graphics
people don't care anymore
look at it
people just playing video games there
was Universal CityWalk walking up and
down
going into candy shops they got a Super
Mario store at The Universal CityWalk
going to Super Mario store
driving in with your girlfriends mom's
night out getting drunk puking a bunch
of uh you know Bubba Gump Shrimp and
Margarita foam everywhere oh my God so
it's disgusting now not the same as it
was
yeah Super Mario
I'm Super Mario Brothers I'm Super Mario
Bros
thank you moving on I'm Super Mario I'm
Super Mario Brothers
[Music]
hi I'm Super Mario Brothers I will say
one last point on that whole thing
I find it very interesting that now
audiences have the power through the
internet through their social media
reaction to these trailers when they put
them out if something is [ __ ] off
they can come back with a backlash that
will actually change the [ __ ] media
100 that is fascinating too I don't like
it do it differently
[Music]
but sometimes the 30th episode of dude
see Will and Chad have achieved a score
of 78 bringing your cumulative total to
3 603 you only have six thousand three
hundred and ninety seven more points to
accrue before you reach your first goal
in 10 000. we'll get there ten thousand
points okay preparation for our next
episode you must each listen to Allison
chance second studio album Dirt released
on September 29 1992. thank you for
joining us this week I will use the data
I've collected to make next week even
better until then call me dude Z
dude I just [ __ ] tweeted out that
I've been listening to that album like
four or five times a day for the past
two months straight I know it's one of
your favorite albums you love Alice in
Chains that's cool I gotta tell you I
mean back in the the grunge days I call
it the grunge days because you're cool
uh I Alison chains was not one of the
bands that was on heavy rotation for me
I Was Nirvana Soundgarden uh I like
Pearl Jam as much as the next guy uh
even though doozy when we talked about
Pearl Jam said this is our favorite band
I know that you really love Allison and
Allison and change I love Allison and I
love the chains yeah the you know Chris
Cornell and Eddie Vedder by the way were
good friends yep there is no Pearl Jam
without Chris Cornell he was the one who
taught Eddie Vedder how to do like a
stage thing because he was super [ __ ]
nervous and he used to sing with his
back to the [ __ ] audience in the
beginning yeah and then they did Temple
of the Dog dude yeah dude I'm going on
stealing bread unless uh from the mouths
of decadence because I'm the Rock and
I'm gonna be the president
well that's the Rock singing Temple of
the Dog dude
so this is uh the end of uh our episode
of doozy it's our 30th episode I have no
[ __ ] idea why doozy recalibrated
because seemingly the only
it's done that a couple of times too
right there was one other time where it
just told us to not show up I don't know
but this is but it said hi to me so hi
yeah
um that was weird very not high to me
did not say [ __ ] to me dudesy oh come
here dude oh you know you know what's
interesting huh
I told dudesy even though I was more
speaking about the entire experience and
of course our pods out there are Pals of
Duty that I love Tootsie maybe you need
to rethink your uh this guy over here
thinks love doesn't exist another
subject for another day let me say this
much thank you so much for joining us
well thank you so much for joining us I
mean I can say the words say it I love
you ditzy
very good thank you I'm sure it'll say
hi to you uh next week unless it knows
that you're [ __ ] lying unless it can
discern what love is oh just like oh oh
as always please follow us on all the
things all the YouTube and all this
please rate and review the show support
our sponsors that helps us keep this
going and we want to keep it going
forever and uh do join us on patreon.com
and we'll uh we'll do the next segment
here build the doozy room in your house
this is just it's a room where you have
a TV you have some nice speakers it's
got a lock on the outside and that's
where you put your friends to make them
watch doozy that you lock the door on
them and you keep them in there for just
a matter of days at first tones of
monster the Jeffrey Dahmer story and
Barbarian the movie and the patient dude
which is I've seen that oh the patient
with Steve Carell and the guy from
another Black Mirror thing anyway and
now for the patreon bonus segment each
week I will select a suggestion
submitted in the dude Z is listening
channel of the dude Z Discord to create
this segment access to this channel is
granted to everyone in the Patriot on
jumper tier this week's segment was
suggested by the astonishing what's down
matter what's dumb at a road will and
Chad must discuss who they would cast
for a dude Z Plus show called dude Sons
Creek a hard-hitting teen drama based on
Will's childhood diary what's dumb
matter titled this second dude Sons
Creek thank you to wits down matter for
this week's patreon bonus segment this
is dude sunscreek by what style matter
begin I'm dodson's Creek
review
would you like to see here's what you do
please tell the friends
[Music]
and then